bonjour monsieur ce que vous aimez lire
ce mois ci et la fia et georges aval
pour jouer aux cow boys les jeunes le
cul coupât mari ma fille aînée dans
trois jours félicitations c'est la
naissance de ma fille cécile et le pape
a dit moore on dit que c'est les
meilleurs qui partent en premier
bah pas la map ou prêts à la naissance
et elle est maman et un petit couteau
mais moi je brûle et le visage chez un
marabout qu'elle 17 mai c'est juste
péter la jambe ou ce qui est bon c'est
déjà ça ouattara de prendre l'avion
était fausse à ma chérie il n'y a plus
de vol
moi ça fait des heures qu'on est bloqués
sans voix ce passage est à prendre avec
moi
ouais
rhodia bowater as tu veux jouer le plus
cool de faire signer d'une voiture non
fumeur 2132 km c'est parti
ces malades ne suit pas ça lors duquel
bon tir la hache de guerre pour elle
il faut un code maintenant tu m'ouvre la
porte et tu retournes à ta place kaunas
dans des voitures on lancerait vol d'une
camionnette dans l'avion tentative de
fuite station à toutes nos années
gâchées
j'enverrai qu'on veut c'est le mariage
de notre fille ça va être compliqué je
ressemble à 10 comme en voulant devenir
police pompiers russes fois dans ta vie
merci merci merci et bravo d'avoir volé
une voiture de flics pour faire 50 m bon
les gars comme ça si c'est moi qui te
rend bas ok barbichette je parie il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup de fiat la mieux cotée
tu as dû faire un cauchemar à mon avis